foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there is a Darkness coming
okay
yes
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving and if you don't
know
is the perfect way
and if you don't know
of all the threats
from both your past
and future you
've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know
[Music]
I miss the desert
I miss the scene
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us
those days of come and gone perhaps
perhaps not
I don't believe in magic
a few times in my life
things I can't explain
and I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe
so hard to believe
[Music]
[Music]
who is this man I'm her Godfather
get back
I think what we have here in Hollywood
is high Arts it's
nice
[Applause]
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go
I always wanted to be part of something
bigger yes let's go
something that lasts that means
something
[Applause]
foreign
no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that good morning good job for
you I'll do anything that's the jackass
they said to screw us
[Applause]
[Music]
so they Park up through our dress I
ain't ice in my nipples this is natural
close up now
take things
what are your thoughts for the future
shouldn't stand in the way of progress
this is gonna be what it's gonna be
twist whoa
and the girl seems nice she is she has
no idea what's next
there's a new sensibility now people
care about Morris
I've never done nothing except
disappoint people my whole life
but I made it on my terms not theirs
[Music]
what I do means something
it's because of you
and I'm going to bed
[Music]
we were gone for quite a while
no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
seriously dude no don't I don't know
don't forget
where we came from
been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together well
what led to the forever
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
loves now you're just making it sad
[Music]
all right that's the car
oh my God okay
not sure if you know who I am
but I'm about to rule the world
wow yay but there's one problem there's
a human has a mustache just like you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing a magnetical
outfit with a hat with those first name
on it because I don't
know closer is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're horrible oh I got this no
parabola
get it off get it out get it off
there's a huge Universe out there
I have a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
pressure
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why do come to us
I want to keep my family safe
[Music]
treat them as our brothers and sisters
you have to ride
let's do it
Just Breathe breathe
[Applause]
Outcast that's all they see
I see
[Music]
I'm a warrior like you I'm supposed to
fight
protect the people
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get it done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Avatar the way of water experience it in
3D
only in theaters December 16th
[Music]
tickets on sale now
foreign
we should go
millions of dollars worth of cocaine
fell from the sky this morning in
Knoxville Tennessee there's more this
out there they dumped it somewhere I'm
looking for my daughter's first is a
dangerous place
check it out something got into it a
deer Maybe
a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to
go and get it
no don't eat that don't eat that let's
see what kind of effect that has
[Music]
the bear it [ __ ] did cocaine
[Music]
air getting cocaine
a bear it was
hey that's inappropriate
you're safe Bears can't climb trees of
course they can
laughs
baby
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with a man forever
apex predator
high on cocaine
thought of it's mine
oh man you [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with that man
[Music]
we have such good luck in nature
[Music]
what is he doing parking
parallel to what foreign
nothing works you know that you're gone
[Music]
I brought you some food okay bye are you
always this unfriendly I am not
unfriended okay you're not the warm
cuddle
what is that looks like it's yours
nowado you are not taking over my bed
you think you have to do everything on
your own but no one can we can't stand
watching One idiot try to teach another
how to drive it's lesson time clutch in
and break break the car is stopped I
almost hit the car you're sure Ryan's a
hybrid my life was black and white she's
always going to be with you
my father used to smile like that I'm
not smart exactly
[Music]
have a cat
[Music]
the U.S defense department has spent
over a trillion dollars on the most
cutting-edge robot technology
introducing robosanta Plus for the
upcoming holiday season
where are you gonna do this fine
Christmas Eve I was potentially gonna go
meet up with a dude I blown him off
twice already so come on get a drink
with your old pal Robbie what's up with
YouTube uh just grabbing to do I talked
her out of some tender trash you didn't
talk me out of anything for Christmas
Merry Christmas
new animatronic state of the art Santa
Claus featured at our own TW bunkers is
now the subject of international recall
thank you
[Music]
Santa
[Music]
what this guy killed the Kid Next Door
[Music]
[Music]
you hear that hey what
[Music]
you need to give me a gun
[Music]
it's in Oh Santa Claus yeah it's [ __ ]
Santa Claus
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have you heard from the boys down at the
scene yet they're still down there
counting bodies
[Applause]
does the best man have the ring best man
the ring sorry um
there we go
oh
wow
it's the ring essential
you come back from your honeymoon if I'm
not around anymore don't be sad okay
what Adam where the hell are you Sarah
I'm gonna need you to brace yourself
and people you just know for so long
you're like family
I know you your face
your face no
what the hell is this friend of yours
you didn't tell me you were bringing a
goddess to the house
[Music]
it must be worth Fortune priceless
he's so Charming he looks like James
Bond yeah [ __ ] dealers oh who hasn't
sold a bit of drugs I'm like they're
violent criminals is that a bullet hole
this needs to be paid for by Insurance
there's no insurance I have a package
that I need to be delivered
and maybe we can forgive the Broken
Heart
oh
guys lift your arm off and hold it up
any idea how draining it is to be around
you all the time the smuggling drugs
while my wife is being held hostage by a
particularly handsome Italian drug lord
I've fallen under your spouse
it's only one bad we can do 69 it like
we used to do when we were kids you mean
top and Tails yeah top and tail 69 same
thing you know what I mean it's not the
same thing
there might be a life problem with the
drugs
[Music]
are you kidding me
foreign
how lucky was it that it was an extra
plane ticket for me oh really lucky
right so much
saying goodbyes
saying hello
you think your wife can hear you no
a white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
you're going to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds no management we've
known each other since we were
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried
I'm going to need a gun goodbye my
friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
we'll have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
for results and execution
Last Words Winston just happened
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]
holy cow look at this place the
Acoustics are amazing
[Music]
I'm awake
two minutes and two seconds that's a new
record everyone
[Applause]
you gotta Stop scaring the new guys off
I'm leaving for the summer and I need
someone to replace me if only there were
a fine young gentleman with your last
name why do you guys keep insisting that
I hire my son he knows the secret of
this place a night guard I'll just mess
it up when have you ever messed anything
up
everybody yeah
want me to unwrap it for you that won't
be necessary Nicholas I am a master
Swordsman
[Applause]
maybe you could just rip the corner a
little just one more thing don't forget
to lock the basement the basement
oh no this is bad this is very very very
very
turn to rule the world
oh which is going to have to wait a sec
because my foot's asleep
[Music]
the god of Chaos
hey shouldn't you ever scarier name like
okay that works
ah grab my hand that's your hand
should be smooth sailing from here
looks like this place is booby-trapped
get me out of here get me out of here
please this is how we say it like a big
boy
I'm just a stupid kid who's in way over
his head when I was 18 I led the French
Army to victory over the English and I
was only 14 when I led the Lewis and
Clark expedition and law discovered fire
when he was 11.
fire burn I know the feeling
today to say goodbye to [ __ ] much
you are down to your last life
you need to retire
[Music]
oh brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommates well
I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero a
legend this is a person party that's
your party so this is where dignity Goes
To Die the year start coming and they
don't stop coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either
what's your story my story
what are we looking at catch up nine
lives what what
I think you should be having too high no
I am on my last laugh oh no
legendary
wish waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great pools in
Boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish look at me my
lives back okay okay possum face I won't
make you back but first
out
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
[Music]
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
[Music]
you will find your reward does not come
easily
Puss in Boots Goldie Bears all right
let's get it all the way
[Music]
to spare I am nothing when you only have
one life that's what makes it special go
get him tiger hey take it easy
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
is in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
we're all just men
we're not invincible
you just gotta keep your line
I was really good to see you soon what
are you doing
I'm a sales rep get you to check out
some of the specialist muscles
what about you you are still doing the
same thing
so we're way good at corporal
see my dad ever killed anyone
there's a [ __ ] hero Mr Logan I
sympathize with your situation but if he
appears before this court again he'll be
taken from your care
Johnny
[Music]
[Music]
flaky one day
there's nothing
don't test me
you don't [ __ ] want me dad you wish
she was still here and not me
and it's a beautiful crime
[Music]
was the Night Before Christmas perfect
time for a story I think in the near
future it's illegal to take drugs or
drink except for one night the binge as
it's known where it's perfectly legal to
get drunk higher stoned
but this year they did what you wouldn't
believe they moved the binge to
Christmas Eve
what
why oh why did they have to put the
binge on Christmas I shuffling stand by
because you all want to do a bunch of
Slam balls out of Frosty's holes
Andrew We're Not Kids anymore this binge
is our chance to take our lives to the
next level you're gonna fix things with
your family I'm crazy your mom's new
lover you're banging my mom
and I'm gonna propose to Sarah going
over to her dad's house to ask him for
permission you don't want to turn on the
bubbles or nothing I'd like to be able
to see right through to the bottom too
many mysteries in those bubbles
come with me if you want a binge who are
you I'm angel
what it would be like if you were never
born this is terrifying
Jesus this party's dead Grandma you have
a heart condition you should have seen
the [ __ ] we were into back in the 60s
Andrew I lost their Grandma's ring Adam
high off cocaine can you come get me
no Chris did you break out of prison
yeah if it didn't matter because the
binge is on and everyone's excited about
Christmas again hey child what do you
want under the tree this Christmas
the bingers are coming man we're taking
over
oh night all the rules are out the
window
it is Christmas officially you saw my
name wrong why is that house smoking a
cigarette this is what I've been wanting
to say to you the entire night
damn I really was high and drunk when I
wrote These
[Music]
foreign
how good a woman your mama was
she took Colton Briggs the coldest
killer that I've ever met
and she turned him into a family man
I'm almost dead now
[Applause]
laughs
coming in one way or another
tell me the names of the men who do this
as long as that little girl is alive
there's no room for vengeance
[Music]
protecting a killer
from another killer
can you teach me how to shoot
well then you put your hands behind your
back a Brig special
my father wants you done I'll blow her
brains all over this Valley
you ain't scared of nothing
Briggs decides he's coming Colton bridge
is coming he's here sound like he's the
one who's scared
my whole life I'd seen fear in the eyes
of every man I ever
let's do this the old way is my father
still all good man
you boy [ __ ] up the devil
foreign
[Music]
what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really
don't
then
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected we're gonna wake them up
with a wave of passion they've never
felt before
hell yeah without further Ado I give you
the Visionary artist magic mine
the real question
no one's believed in me like a mom has
so what's the show about it's the same
or will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick love your money
the real question is why does she feel
like she has to choose it sounds to me
she just needs to let go
[Music]
some good
maybe that as well
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants
[Music]
wait I know you you were a cop right did
you arrested what's your name Kim
let you out for the warning right
Mr March
everyone says you're mean and crazy
you're right
God damn it why does it have to be so
loud Harry sorry the more he has the
more he wants
[Music]
I don't know what scheme it's rattling
around in that brain to be whereas this
promise me he won't do anything stupid
you're not really going to Mr lapman's
dinner party are you there isn't going
to be a dinner party
whoa we're on a mission
just cut off your brain and give it to
me
really nothing calls for horse hair or
suitable equivalent you seem to like the
doll I'll take four
you beautiful doll
you order the horse here yes do you have
it you ought to be locked up for
anything you want to know about the
destructive witness 20th century who
looks an unwanted neighbor not another
lecture you're very annoying we're both
very annoying
my wife has started writing we were
hoping you could read her novel I could
but I wouldn't don't even think about
how you appear to other people
this game of Bruce will mess up
everything
you're not an 18th century man you're
acting crazy you're talking to Hector
it's the only news I'm coming to the new
undertaking that will not only gratify
me personally
also save much of civilization
hang in there Harry the end is near here
as if I needed reminding
you've been a wonderful audience I'm
here till Doomsday
hello can you drive me today are you
ready to go now yeah just give me like
five seconds
[Music]
uh Jake we should just occupy every
Country Joe I agree with you Lila thank
you Ziggy how do you agree with Lila oh
[ __ ] excuse my brain for knowing what
not to
[Music]
thanks for tuning in
mom
mom [ __ ] sorry did you try to open the
door while I was live streaming what's
live streaming that's where I have 20
000 followers I'm validated and I'm
starred which is Terror hard to get just
make sure you don't play the blues what
white people playing blues music is
cultural appropriation I play classic
folk rock with alternative influences I
don't know what that means and then you
called the police I called them you're
in the right place you're safe and
you'll have two beds for as long as you
need he's my little nine Shining Armor
it's true kids are just pure love you
know what I mean
the hell are you doing installing a red
Beacon right so people know when I'm
live streaming and by people I mean you
Ziggy you don't have to be interested in
politics you think I'm stupid no no I
didn't say that I brought you this hat
Kyle it was my sons but he no longer
wears it I don't know what he wears
anymore
[Music]
yes boys your age can't bring themselves
to be kind and you can't help yourself
you're a special person
are you happy I think so why are you
asking me because I'm reading this
article about teen suicide and it's
highest in your age group okay thanks
Mom's home
when you're a little boy you're my
little Ally your life is going to be
happier you were going to be one of the
good ones and then something switched in
you
you stopped being interested in anything
outside your own little world
can you take me to school are you ready
to go right now I'm right here dude
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you do
there is still time for you
we'll show you the way to the kingdom of
heaven
repent
or you will be left for the final
cleansing
[Laughter]
what are you doing back here are you
okay who's this she's from that weirdo
cold
I think they're gonna leave for heaven
before the rest of us
was that your mother
what happened to her
you don't want to call this kind of
thingy and it just creates more problems
now I just gotta clean it up are you
gonna go home you can't go home
we have a rule you stay you work but if
you work we take care of you because
it's rough out there
well good buddy
sure I am looking for a little fun
your mind has been poisoned
I know it is not your fault you are so
beautiful oh you don't have to be scared
I couldn't hurt a fly
so
I am ready for you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]